Let's go through and figure out what each
of the composite functions for every pair
here would be.
Then we can answer whether or not they're
the same.
For this first pair we have f of x equals
x squared, and g of x equals x plus 1.
That means that f composed with g would
give us x plus 1 squared.
But if we have g composed with f, then
instead, we get x squared, plus 1.
These are not the same, so let's check no.
For the next one we have f of x, equals x
plus 1, and g of x equals x plus 2, and
in this case both of our compositions are
the same.
It doesn't matter.
Whether we add 2 and then 1, or 1 and
then 2 to x.
In both cases, we end up with x plus 3.
So, let's check yes for this one.
Interesting, and now for the fun part.
Is putting on your left shoe, and then
putting on your right shoe, going to give
you the same outcome as putting on your
right shoe, and then putting on your left shoe?
Well in both cases, you're going to end
up with both shoes on your feet.
So, yes.
F of g, and g of f, are the same.
Now, we have one function, as putting on
your shoes, and the other as putting on
your socks.
So, is putting on your socks and then
your shoes, the same as putting on your
shoes and then your socks?
Well, in one case, we end up with a
pretty normal situation, socks underneath shoes.
In the other case, though, when we have
shoes underneath our socks, You'd
probably be pretty uncomfortable.
Your socks might not even fit over your shoes.
Either ways, socks underneath shoes or
shoes underneath socks, are not the same thing.
So we're going to have to check no on
this one.
And last but not least, we have two
functions that are getting dressed and
taking a shower.
Now, one of these seems to produce a
pretty normal everyday activity.
You take a shower and then you get dressed.
But, what if we did things the other way
around?
I, for one, would be pretty sad if I put
on my favorite dress and then got in the
shower and got myself soaking wet.
That would not be a great start to my day.
So I think we can safely say that taking
a shower, and then getting dressed, is
very different from getting dressed, and
then taking a shower.
So no, the two compositions of these
functions that we could do are not the same.